at the heart of digital challenges
the cea list offers solutions for the
responsible development of
digital systems in terms of performance
frugality and trust
our research programs opens up
software engineering
digital instrumentation the industry
of the
future cybersecurity is obviously
the  artificial intelligence and our
historical expertise in the security
of system software led the cv
liste to be among the first to have
underlined in 2017
the importance of the issue of trust
for the industrial deployment
of artificial intelligence.
moreover, which has become a
strategic program of the cea from 2019, which
aims to develop solutions
for the qualification of data and
knowledge, the characterization and
validation of applications and the
certification of systems based
on artificial intelligence fundamental
for a large industrial deployment
n  bringing autonomy
to emb-related systems  arquer imposes multiple requirements, in
particular the
frugality given and
integration resources on specialized hardware targets
and the requirement of
fairly broad confidence from a simple guarantee of
quality and performance to an assurance
of the safety of critical systems
the expertise of the cea list teams
allow it to address the subject of
trust marked from start to finish from the
signal to give houde and
knowledge to deployment on
hardware architectures
the multi-domain nature of the program and
the vision  overall
end-to-end trust nury
are at the heart of the service's strategy and
programs with the
trust program and go we integrate a rich
collective for industrial use
and expertise which allows us
to amplify the development of
operational solutions for
deployment to managers of the
iaa has long been committed to a
platform development process
These tools, in particular open source,
will contribute to the
trust program and go to the
implementation of sovereign solutions
for trusted AI
[Music]